before we get started thank you so much
to monday.com for sponsoring today's
video
so while i don't work professionally as
a software engineer anymore products
like monday.com really help me to stay
organized with all the things that i
have going on
monday.com is an online work os platform
where teams can create custom workflows
in minutes
to run their project processes and
everyday work
and it's a really exciting time because
the monday apps framework allows any
developer to create a custom framework
on top of monday.com
the monday apps marketplace just
launched in october and so if you build
an app on their platform
then hundreds of thousands of
organizations using monday can use your
app
and because it's pretty dang new you can
also be one of the first
monday app developers and because of
first movers advantage
your app can be the go-to in the
category that you choose to build in
and developing on the framework is
intuitive and they even have an
api playground to allow you to build
apps really quickly and
easily so register to app challenge for
a chance to win a tesla
last day of submission is may 3rd thank
you to monday for sponsoring and now
let's get back to the video
hey everyone how's it going my name is
mayuko and welcome back to my channel
today is like a reflections video
about how i kind of haven't coded
in like a whole year march kind of marks
one year of stepping like full-time into
content creation
and leaving this kind of software
engineering career on pause
and i was trying to figure out what
video to make this time and i was like i
should probably make a technical video
because i haven't done that in a while
but then every time that i like went
into the research part of it i was like
i really don't want to though like i
really really don't want to
because again i haven't coded
professionally in a whole year
so i'm not sure if i'm allowed to talk
about this and then i was like
this is what i should make my video
about and so today i've gathered a
couple of
thoughts they're going to be kind of
like stream of consciousness a little
bit where i talk pretty open and
honestly
to you about what it's been like to not
really have coded for a year
this video requires me to be really
vulnerable which means that i've been
kind of procrastinating it because it's
hard to be really vulnerable
on topics like this so please be kind in
the comments
and i guess just to kind of give you
like a look ahead there's good news and
bad news i guess
there's things that i didn't realize
about myself after having not coded for
a year
that are good and there's also bad
things and feelings and realizations
that come with it as well
so i'm going to talk about all that and
this is just like my own opinion my own
experiences
as usual on this channel so this isn't
meant to generalize anybody's experience
but i wanted to talk about what's been
going on in here
i'm gonna start with the bad news first
and then end on the good news because i
do think there is like a silver lining
to all of this
so the bad news is i feel like weekly i
have
feelings about not being legit enough as
a software engineer
i feel very impostory like the feelings
of imposter syndrome that i thought
might be behind me at least the really
strong feelings of feelings of imposter
syndrome
are very much alive and well in my brain
and i think specifically it's like in
silicon valley
a lot of what your identity is is
related to your work like you go to a
party
one of the first things that you ask
even if it's not a work related party is
just like oh so what do you do
or like where do you work and so it's
very career focused and career oriented
in the valley
and so i think like i was part of that
world and so i felt like
being a software engineer being ios
developer
coding as my nine to five was a really
like strong part of my identity i guess
like that's just how
i defined myself often nowadays that's
not the case because maybe you've seen
in some of my videos or the content that
i create that i describe myself in a
very different way now
i still say that i'm a software engineer
but i'm also a content creator
i'm a japanese and american person child
of immigrants
like wife mother to two dogs like
there's a lot of other parts but
in the past the whole software engineer
part was kind of just like that is
who i was so yeah because of that i
think like when i
stopped working professionally as a
software engineer
it was a lot of just like if i'm not
working as a software engineer then like
what does that mean like who
am i anymore because you know what leave
it to me my yuko for having an identity
crisis
any time anything about me changes and
yeah honestly i feel this like often
because of the content that i choose to
create and the communities that i'm a
part of
i'm often reminded by others or by
myself
that i don't code professionally anymore
and so that's not like my main thing
and so then i talked to scott about it
usually on our evening walks because i'm
just like scott
what like authority do i have in talking
about technology and coding and career
and stuff if that's not what i'm
currently doing right now
in fact anytime like a tech youtuber
leaves their job or they change roles to
something other than software
engineering i've heard that it's like a
pretty common sentiment that it's just
like am i gonna still seem legitimate
and real and relatable and
just like valuable
valid to my youtube audience or whatever
audience if i'm not doing that right now
as a job
when i first left my job i was kind of
just like yeah because i still have so
much stuff in my brain like all the
knowledge and the skills that i built
are not for nothing like it's still
there and so yeah i think at the
beginning it was fine but now it's a
year later and so if anything it's just
like the rift
between software engineering and me just
only grows bigger
and so when i really think about like
what is it about that rift that makes me
so uncomfortable is that it's just
fear and i think the fear specifically
is because a lot of the conversation or
sentiment around software engineering is
that
if you leave then you become rusty or
you become outdated or out of touch or
something like that
and so i just feel a lot of fear that
that's gonna be who i am like i'm gonna
be out of touch
and the stuff that i create and the
stuff that i do and the person that i am
is no longer going to be valid and so
every time i like
kind of venture back into coding
technical land it's just a lot of fear
because it's just like
oh right i left this entire life on
pause to do what i wanted to do
it's just scary like what if i go back
and they don't accept me what if i go
back and i
my skills have actually gotten worse or
something like that so my confidence
just generally is very down
but like granted when i like
realistically think about it and
logically think about it like do
i think that i could go back to software
engineering if i wanted to and if i
really try
like yeah i think so i realized that the
amount of time that i spent in tech
all the stuff that i know is really like
never gonna go away like all of that is
going to be
a strong part of who i am so yeah i
think remembering that
like kind of just makes me check that
it's just like yeah okay so you're not
coding professionally anymore
like what does that mean well when you
do go back to coding maybe it means that
you have to google a little bit more
because you're rusty and you don't
remember certain words or phrases or how
to do things
but once you look at that it kind of
like brings this flood of memories back
so
it's not impossible i guess and also
like it's not like i've coded zero lines
in this last year i've done a couple of
personal projects dabbled here and there
it's just like i don't do it as
frequently as i used to and it's not
like my main
skill or main trade anymore and a
question comes up often in my mind too
of like
well i don't know if i'm so afraid of
leaving coding does that mean that i
want to go back to coding and honestly
i don't know like i i don't have a
definitive answer for that right now
i'm like do i want to go into coding
maybe you want to go into something
completely different
i just have no answers and i think
that's okay even though sometimes i'm
scared that i don't even have an answer
to that
honestly so yeah it's just been a lot of
imposter syndrome
and thinking about what you all think of
me and hoping that
the stuff that i'm talking about still
makes sense and that i'm still
like valued i guess because when you
work so hard
at a career to feel valid and valued by
an entire industry and then you leave
that behind
oh baby isn't scary and frankly it's
giving me
some perspective i think too because
there are a lot of people who leave tech
and then come back for whatever reason
maybe they take a sabbatical for a year
maybe they have to care for a loved one
maybe they go on maternity leave and
then they quit their job be a full-time
mom or
full-time dad for a while and then they
come back into the industry
and there is kind of like this i think
tech retention issue
especially in women in that as time goes
on
within someone's career they're less
likely to stick with tech like there's a
leaky bucket problem
and so when i think about all the
feelings that i have about
going back into coding technology in
general
the tech industry i'm like yeah i don't
know like i get it it's scary it's
really scary so yeah it's been a lot of
second guessing i'm very like i don't
know like the whole i was never like a
tech
like a really tech heavy or coding
channel to begin with my stuff has been
very light touch tech
and kind of overall career related stuff
and i try to bring value in that way
because
there are so many other great channels
that explain coding and do tutorials and
stuff and i think they're incredible
and i guess like i think that those are
filling a
gap that i could never satisfy in the
way that they are
and so i'd rather work on other things
and frankly it's just i don't i'm not
interested in making coding tutorials i
it's just not what excites me about
content creation
rather making this kind of stuff about
putting my feelings on the internet
and showing you the raw realness of
being human
and being the person that i am and hope
that you relate and find value or advice
or something like that so
even that as i keep going on in content
creation
i'm just gonna have been further away
from tech
for longer and longer so does that mean
that i'm gonna keep making tech content
who knows you know i feel like i
constantly have to challenge in order to
be able to give tech advice you have to
be actively working in tech but
i don't actually think that has to be
true either i don't know
i guess it's just like the imposter
syndrome is very
real it's been a rough journey it's uh
constantly
like doubting myself for the path that
i've taken
and being scared of everything every
time i look at code or
the other day i opened lead code and i
noped out of there so fast because i was
just like this just reminds me of all
the things that i've forgotten
and that hurts me because i don't know
being reminded that time is passing and
that your brain is not perfect and that
you're forgetting things
can be scary but also i do have the
confidence that i could figure it out if
i wanted to
that's kind of the silver lining and
speaking of silver linings let's get
into like the pros
which really are kind of more like
through being able to
leave tech and not work professionally
as a software engineer here are other
things that i learned as a result
and the one thing that has really
surprised me
about not working as a software engineer
professionally for a year
is that all of the other skills related
to software engineering that aren't
coding
are super transferable skills in my
current role
i feel like it's really similar to like
playing one sport for
most of your life and then switching to
another sport i know sport
allergies are not like the best thing
but just like hang in there with me so
basically
in that first sport that you do if you
build up the muscle the endurance
you get the flexibility in your body to
be able to do that sport
then in that second sport you still have
this like baseline of just like
being able to move and do stuff with
your body but you're just gonna use
and flex a different set of muscles and
those muscles are probably ones that you
built up in the first sport
and if anything you're gonna work on a
completely different body part like
maybe
this second sport you're more likely to
use like your leg muscles and stuff and
you're maybe not gonna flex like your
arm muscles as much
or something so that's kind of what it
feels like it's like
all the stuff that i learned as a
software engineer i've actually taken
with me
and certain parts of the skills that i
learned
are now just being flexed more or less
and so coding specifically is one of the
ones that i use
way way less which is what feeds the
imposter syndrome and scares me a little
bit
but i think when i get really scared
i remind myself that yeah but look at
all these other skills that you've been
able to develop on top of your existing
software engineering skills that weren't
coding and frankly
like when i thought about leaving my job
these are the skills that i wanted to
build and so
it's kind of cool to look back and be
like yeah yeah i did that
so i use that as a way to like boost my
confidence sometimes
literally if you think about like what
are the skills of a software engineer i
feel like
generally colloquially people divide
them into hard skills and soft skills
when in fact there's actually
way more buckets than just that in my
opinion like the ability
for instance to be able to read
technical documentation and make sense
of it is a very
important software engineering skill
especially as you get more senior and
there aren't answers of stack overflow
things everywhere so
that's one thing especially when i'm
working with editing software
when i'm like reading about anything new
that is written by
academia or anyone like that being able
to get information that way i think is
a really important part of my job
currently being able to google
everything like getting really good at
googling is something that i developed
as a software engineer
and literally like being my own boss and
like not really having
like somebody else who could do my job
means that i'm the
only person sometimes you can figure out
how to do what i want to do which means
it's a lot of googling another skill
that i've been really thankful for
that i use in my day-to-day is just like
project planning and project management
because i'm not sure if you know this
but like in content creation
everything is like a project a video is
a project there's multiple steps
to get it from conceptualization to like
pushing to broad basically which is
youtube as well as just like
making newsletters going live on twitch
like there's so many
things to do all the time and because
i'm my own boss a lot of the time i'm
doing all of it
and so in order to stay organized
literally i still
do sprints i still run my day
and work in sprints and tasks and
prioritize all the lists of tasks and
stuff and that's a very like
i brought that exactly from scrum days
you know one other really important
skill that i
learned as a software engineer that i
use often is my collaboration skills
like even though i work for myself by
myself i still collaborate with many
people
granted it's not like we all work for
the same company or something and it's a
lot of like strangers on the internet
but it's all about just like
getting people to work on something with
you to make something
and that's that's basically software
engineering and coding so yeah i think
the silicon valley mentality has
followed me
in being organized in collaboration so
it's like
setting up meetings while in advance
creating agendas for the meetings
creating
action items for those meetings
following up in those meetings
trying to find alignment and a common
ground in communication with another
person
whose background you have no idea about
and related to that is like writing good
documentation for other people to read
writing good emails being able to manage
like good relationships and
foster good relationships with
collaborators
all of that like all of that are lessons
that i learned as a software engineer
kind of like how hey if i'm gonna do you
a favor
i kind of expect at some point for you
to do me a favor like all of that stuff
is like so incredibly important in
content creation
and so that's been really interesting oh
and one other thing that's been super
helpful
is literally like debugging like i still
debug in my day-to-day
pretty often especially when premiere
pro is being like super difficult to
work with or when i'm trying to get down
to
the bottom of any sort of issue whether
that be like with merch
or with youtube or with any technology
ever because being a content creator
still means using a lot of digital
products just the building blocks are
different
so yeah i think what i learned from not
coding professionally for a full year
is that it just required me to have a
different perspective
about myself my work my skills
my confidence it wasn't easy but
honestly everything considered i'm happy
that i
did what i did and frankly it's quite
scary to post a video on the internet
about this because i am really worried
about what people think
and so i hope that you'll still follow
along with me
in my journey and subscribe to my
channel because
i don't know i still feel like there's a
lot of other things to talk about
within the world of tech that isn't just
coding
to me coding is a tool it's not the
end-all be-all
of everything it's just a tool similar
to like how
a saw is to a carpenter it's one tool
that you use
to get what you want done and it does
unlock a lot of capabilities
because it's cool and ever evolving and
a lot of people are working on it but
there is just so much more to the world
of tech that
i want to talk about so i hope you
indulge me in that
and you don't think of me as a complete
fraud
i sure hope you don't think that thank
you for watching my musings
that come right off the top of my head i
appreciate you all for being here and
watching my videos
because you'll give me purpose in the
work that i do
and validate that it's okay to like live
your life the way that you want to
and that's very very reassuring so
thank you all so much every single
person who watches
my videos leaves nice comments watches
my twitch streams buys merch
joins my youtube membership club like i
feel nothing but
just immense gratitude for all of you in
following along in my journey so thank
you i have
big amazing things in store this year
and i cannot wait to tell you all about
them
so stay tuned i guess like in all of
this
while it's scary and everything makes me
fearful usually still because you know
what your girl has anxiety i am still
very much excited about the future and
what's to come
and yeah i don't know where i'm headed i
don't know what i'm gonna do but
i'm realizing that sometimes that's just
way more exciting and that's not a scary
thing
and i'm coming around to that all right
everybody i'll see you in the next one
bye